[Musique]
Véronique prince Hélène buzetti Michel
seoget bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir je dis à
la ministre tout à l'heure on peut pas
s'empêcher de penser ici à la garderie
le camion bélier puis c'est gestes
intentionnelle mais on verra on verra je
vais je vous envoie sur le Parti
québécois en fin de semaine je pense
c'est la grosse nouvelle politique je
vous fais entendre Paul Saint-Pierre
plat Mondon qui a eu un score ma foi
digne de la Corée du Nord c'est 98,5
c'est une période exaltante pour militer
aux parties québécois
qu'on passe le mot aux quatre coins du
Québec il y a un parti qui bâtit
l'avenir qui bâtit un avenir meilleur et
qu'il fait dans la bonne humeur le
respect et l'optimisme je ressens votre
énergie puis j'en suis tellement heureux
c'est un geste qui va droit au cœur
à la lumière de ce qu'on a vécu côte à
côte dans les derniers mois c'est à dire
des montagnes russes
il y a plusieurs personnes ici qui ont
fait des sacrifices importants
alors je vous montre le score qui avait
obtenu les autres chefs parce que le PQ
a souvent été difficile pour ces chefs
durs pour ses chefs Jean-François les
avaient eu quand même 92 madame Marois
93 elle était la plus élevée jusqu'ici
Bernard Landry qui a démissionné 76.20
le samedi soir il y a son équipe je m'en
vais le regretter d'ailleurs mais il est
parti Lucien Bouchard c'était à Québec
76 il était parti dans sa chambre
d'hôtel et avait réfléchi à quitter
aussi mais lui était resté et Jacques
Parisot 92% bon Véronique
il y a beaucoup de paradoxes c'est
intéressant parce que le PQ a quand même
faut le rappeler je m'excuse de le
rappeler mais a eu le pire score de son
histoire mais là ils ont réussi depuis
l'élection et même avant à transformer
ça en espoir c'est qu'il y a eu en fait
plein de petites victoires et
l'expression un éléphant ça se mange une
bouchée à la fois moi ça me fait un peu
penser à ça parce que rappelez-vous
avant la campagne électorale quand on
demandait après le meilleur premier
ministre quel est le chef que vous
reconnaissez le plus avant la campagne
en nous dernier je vous rappelle que
Paul Saint-Pierre Plamondon était à 2%
dans un sondage Léger et dans le dernier
qui est paru quelques jours il était
rendu à 69 % donc il avait un déficit de
notoriété très important comblé il est
en train de le combler parce que c'est
un peu le renouveau du Parti québécois
visage plus jeune père de famille avec
des enfants qui incarnent Thomas le
renouveau qui a pas le style hargnieux
qui fait moins de partisanneries par
exemple que c'est prédécesseur alors il
est en train de se faire connaître faut
pas oublier aussi que le Parti québécois
au niveau de ses finances ça allait
tellement pas bien en 2020 il avait un
déficit de cumulé de 2,4 millions de
dollars il était sur le bord de la
faillite ni plus ni moins puis il avait
reçu les avertissements des banques et
tout ça pour lui dire là vous allez tout
droit dans un mur et bien il a réussi en
fait à rembourser sa dette puis de
repartir avec un sol POS ce qui est un
peu un exploit là quand vous parlez à
des gens qui sont dans le monde des
finances là c'est quand même quelque
chose qu'ils aient réussi ça et donc
tout ça fait en sorte que ça donne
l'espoir en plus que l'appui à la
souveraineté jamais été aussi levée
depuis un petit peu avant de temps quand
même à 38 %, alors tout ça fait en sorte
qu'en fin de semaine les militants
étaient de bonne humeur Hélène buzetti
Michel soget c'est comme si les gens
avaient l'impression qu'ils peuvent pas
aller plus bas et là ils remontent puis
comme un optimisme qui s'est installé
dans ce partie là Hélène oui bah en fait
c'est votre de confiance sont plus une
jauge du à quel point le chef atteint
les attentes qu'on avait et visiblement
les attentes envers le Parti québécois
était basse et ce n'est pas pour rien
enlever à Paul saint-pierre-plamondon
Véronique a très bien expliqué à quel
point ici illustré avec la campagne
électorale et tout ça la question de la
monarchie maintenant en moins les sont
très très basses on savait que ce
parti-là ne formerait pas le
gouvernement moi je fais souvent une
comparaison avec ce qui est arrivé au
NPD sur la sainte fédérale vous aviez
Thomas molker qui au sortir de
l'élection 2015 avait obtenu le deuxième
meilleur score de l'histoire de ce parti
et c'est quand même fait montrer la
porte pour parler militants obtenant
moins de 50 % parce que on pensait que
cette fois là aurait dû être la bonne il
aurait dû gagner alors que celui qui le
qui lui succédé job meeting obtient des
scores beaucoup plus modestes et obtient
un meilleur appui de ces militants alors
c'est vraiment les attentes et la
question de la souveraineté y est pour
beaucoup c'est un sujet qui revient à
l'ordre du jour que le Parti québécois
et son chef remet remettent à l'ordre du
jour ne se gêne pas pour parler de cet
enjeu et ça explique premièrement
pourquoi il y a un petit élan là de
renaissance chez les militants c'est
intéressant ce jeu des attentes que vous
compliqué les attentes étaient tellement
bases il a il a réussi à dépasser
largement toutes les attentes Paul
Saint-Pierre Plamondon Michel COG
l'intérêt pour Monsieur Saint-Pierre
platmondo c'est de voir que la
souveraineté à 38 et qui sont partis à
18 donc il y a de la il y a de l'espace
pour grandir et c'est ça qui est
intéressant pour lui c'est que on ne le
voit pas actuellement comme un chef de
partie qui est en train de descendre que
et le je sais que j'en ai été critique
moi-même mais toute l'histoire du
serment au roi cette victoire morale sur
quelque chose qui est pas sur le fond
mais c'est ça qui est pékistes voulaient
il voulait ça faisait longtemps qu'il y
avait rien gagné et ils ont très fier de
ça alors maintenant il faut voir comment
on amène ça à l'Assemblée nationale où
il y a quand même juste une question des
fois deux par semaine c'est pas une très
bonne façon d'avoir de la notoriété on a
vu qu'ils sont donnés un plan à quatre
étapes pour faire parler d'eux en dehors
de la chance c'est une bonne chose alors
faudra voir comment on gère tout ça
d'ici les quatre prochaines années
ça peut être long ils sont juste trois à
la fin et je sais perdre mon temps était
élu parce que il y a quelqu'un qui avait
pris des clients dans une boîte à
lettres là faut pas faut pas l'oublier
alors
ils ont beaucoup de travail mais ils ont
ils ont de l'espoir ils ont de l'espace
pour grandir
vous avez parlé du serment roi vous qui
aimez le baseball Michel c'est un coup
de circuit en terme de communication
politique de ça coûte circuit là qu'ils
ont
ce midi quelque chose de fort
intéressant vous avez dit vous avez fait
une analogie botanique là vous avez dit
il faut pas oublier qu'actuellement ce
qui encourage le Parti québécois c'est
qu'un terreau nationaliste au Québec qui
est la date et la pousse vous avez dit
verte mais je veux dire bleu la poche
bleue du PQ la jeune pousse et dans un
terreau sympathique c'est pas comme si
le gouvernement était très fédéraliste
il y a un gouvernement nationaliste qui
leur donne un peu de d'air non
en tout cas qui m'apparaît à être comme
l'antichambre du souverainisme piqué si
je veux dire
c'est exactement c'est parce que la CAQ
se dit maintenant fédéralisme mais en
vrai véritablement un discours
nationaliste que ce soit sur l'identité
la laïcité la langue bon les espaces
bleus ensuite le panier bleu on mousse
beaucoup cette fibre nationaliste ce qui
n'est pas pour déplaire aux militants
pékistes qui croit au Québec pays alors
il y a quand même un discours ambiant
politique en ce moment dans lequel on
n'entend pas beaucoup la voix
fédéraliste forte comme à une autre
époque par exemple monsieur Couillard
qui était un farouche fédéralisme ou
même avant ça les grands débats avec des
Stéphane Dion sur la Fédérale notamment
on entend plus ça des gens pour donner
la réplique systématiquement à ceux qui
disent ah le Québec pourrait faire un
pays alors il y a comme de l'espace et
et c'est comme si Monsieur le ouvrait
cet espace et que le PQ peut ensuite
grandir là-dessus et Michel le disait
bien quand tu parlais de la pluie à la
souveraineté qui est à 38% versus plus
ou moins 18 pour le PQ il y a de
l'espace pour grandir et cet espace-là
je pense il est créé par ce discours
ambiant qu'entretien notamment la CAQ
c'est intéressant Véronique parce qu'on
disait aux dernières élections que
monsieur Legault
en passer aucune au PQ la puisqu'il y
avait même intérêt à ce que presque le
parti meurt mais dans le fond peut-être
pas là peut-être pas faut pas oublier
que des vases communiquées entre la CAQ
puis le parti québécoise puis les gens
partent québécois se disent ceux qui
vont un moment donné cette année de la
carte parce que ça va être inévitable il
y a une usure du pouvoir qui va
s'installer mais ces gens-là qui
croyaient que le PQ est un vieux
véhicule pour citer les sciences mais
ces gens-là vont avoir envie de revenir
parce qu'ils vont voir que ça va bien
aux parties québécois puis en ce moment
il mise beaucoup justement sur
enthousiasme là pour déjà commencer les
démarches de recrutement de candidats
qui est quand même très tôt on s'entend
le vent le temps de tourner 10 fois
jusqu'à la prochaine élection mais quand
même il y a beaucoup d'enthousiasme en
ce moment parce que quoi ils doivent
peut-être juste faire attention de pas
avoir des excès dans enthousiasme le
décalage avec le réel aussi oui Michel
ouais mais c'est ça ce qui fait la
fortune de la CAQ c'est une gouvernance
à la péquiste Bernard lambris à peu près
mais pas de référendum à un moment donné
il va falloir comme je suis simplement
dans des esprit on va faire référendum
et son parti et peut-être plus précis le
programme actuellement il dit référendum
dans un premier mandat donc
ça ça peut refroidir beaucoup de monde
ça c'est le dangereuse pour grandir d'un
autre côté ils ont quand même le
référendum dans le programme puisque
c'est peut-être pas le mot le plus
populaire actuellement au Québec
très bien alors merci à vous trois je
voulais parler d'un petit mot rapide
rapide sur la partiel ce soir combat
entre les libéraux justement voici un
code PQ n'est pas vraiment dans la
course je vais me permettre de le dire
mais particules d'un côté et parti
libérale de l'autre et
oui si le Parti libéral perd c'est une
catastrophe s'il gagne on dira bof il a
maintenu les acquis alors que si Québec
solidaire père on serait bof mais s'il
gagne ça serait extraordinaire et ils
pourront utiliser ça justement contre le
PQ parce qu'il y a une guerre entre ces
deux parties à savoir lequel est
vraiment l'avenir et donc une victoire
de QS pourrait être utilisée contre le
PQ ça c'est clair on a on a devoir se
Véronique ce soir les résultats
absolument ce sont les deux parties qui
ont le plus à perdre Québec soldat
pourrait montrer si le père que c'est un
parti qui stagne et le Parti libéral de
son côté c'est le père ça va accentuer
on dirait la descente ou la perception
que ça va mal Michel vous regardez ça ce
soir 21h
ok c'est ce soir que ça se passe merci
beaucoup au 3 merci à vous trois au
revoir au revoir pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici
RDI